and speaking by the way of Jim Jordan
weaponizing the weaponization committee
it was revealed this week that Jim
Jordan has sent letters to multiple
different colleges and universities
across the country
demanding all of the information about
their efforts to research
disinformation in American politics
according to the letter
that Jim Jordan sent to these colleges
he said quote certain third parties
including organizations like yours may
have played a role in this censorship
regime by advising on so-called
misinformation
so he's going after colleges now he
already failed and going after Twitter I
mean we all remember Matt Tybee coming
in there and testifying and uh
didn't didn't go so well and if you've
been paying attention to the most recent
drama between taibi and musk uh that
relationship has had a horrible falling
out but Jim Jordan so far has come up
with nothing with this weaponization
committee
so he is grasping at straws now remember
when he brought in those FBI so-called
whistleblowers that all turned out to be
extremist Trump supporters who actually
hated the FBI so they weren't actually
whistleblowers they were just mad at the
agency because they didn't like it and
then they delivered no explosive
Bombshells in their testimony and it was
revealed of course that a couple of them
had actually gotten some money from Kosh
Patel one of Donald Trump's close allies
uh from his group yeah it was a whole
big mess and it made Jim Jordan look
very stupid just like the Twitter files
hearing made him look very stupid
so now he's going after colleges he's
saying how dare you how dare you
research misinformation
and then how dare you I suspect
give that information to social media
companies or the Biden Administration
now the thing is based on the letter Jim
Jordan doesn't even know that that
happened
Jim Jordan is just making these wild
accusations against colleges saying I
think you probably may have could have
at some point thought about possibly
thinking about doing these things
That's the basis for this investigation
folks
the problem is even though these
colleges have nothing to hide
they also don't want to have to spend
time hiring lawyers you know sending
their people down to Washington DC to go
and testify wasting man hours going
through all of their research compiling
it in a way that Congress can actually
read
that takes time and money
something that a lot of colleges don't
necessarily have a lot of on hand
especially for something like this
so according to some of the researchers
at these colleges
they're already worried that this is
going to have a chilling effect on their
efforts to combat misinformation in the
United States
ahead of the 2024 election
multiple sources who spoke to propublica
about this story say that they are
worried that colleges rather than have
to live under Congressional scrutiny
we'll simply scrap the programs or scale
them back to the point where they become
completely ineffective
and that's the goal
that's what Jim Jordan wants that's what
Republicans want
they don't want colleges and
universities you know smart people
looking at the amount of misinformation
flowing all day every day on social
media
because what is that going to point
fingers back to
it's not going to point fingers back to
this show it's not going to point
fingers back to my show
it's not going to point fingers at at
Sam cedar or any of the other folks who
do this Jesse dolomore no it's not going
to come after us
it's going to come after your your
Charlie Kirks and your Candace Owens and
your Fox news's and your daily wires
daily callers daily morons whatever it
is those are the ones that are going to
get flagged for misinformation
because those are the ones that are
filled
with misinformation with disinformation
with lies of omission
if you've spent any time
watching conservative media reading
conservative Outlets
you quickly begin to realize as a
rational person
um there are some things missing here
there's some context missing there's a
quote that you've taken and distorted
that is commonplace in a lot of
conservative media
sometimes they just outright make things
up and they never get held accountable
right we're not seeing slander libel and
defamation lawsuits filed left and right
against these organizations
we should but we don't
so the only weapon we have are these
institutions that are actively
investigating misinformation and calling
it out and Reporting on it
and Jim Jordan knows that and he also
knows we're heading into a contentious
2024 election cycle he doesn't want
people hyper focused on the lies coming
from the right so he's trying to have
this chilling effect on This research
through his requests to these colleges
that is the point of it that is the goal
that is what he wants to do
and some folks at the colleges are
already admitting it's probably going to
work
look I am fair and cousins you can
follow me on YouTube at youtube.com the
ring of fire also youtube.com fair and
balanced I am on Twitter Facebook
Instagram and Tick Tock at
fahrenbalanced this is the David Pacman
show and we'll be right back with more